les derniers tours les gars dernier tour
allez allez les tours de piste
s'enchaînent dans les conditions de
course pour les sites titulaires du pôle
de sport adapté contrairement handisport
en sport adapté le sportif rencontre
uniquement des problématiques cognitives
les petits détails de la course
deviennent donc très importants
je vais modifier ce qui a modifié pour
être prêt pour les championnats du monde
et pour pour être prêt aux courses à
venir
me modifier ce qui a modifie sur la
piste et sur la route les trajectoire
les positions
des réglages qui doivent amener l'or
pour les championnats de France le
week-end prochain sur cette même piste
de Bourges l'objectif c'est de les
mettre en condition réelle
aussi bien sur la partie technique donc
sur le bloc des parts comme on a pu le
voir parce que c'est des exercices assez
spécifiques bien avoir moi je leur parle
de musique du blog départ donc bien
avant la musique du blog des départs
pour ensuite pouvoir faire des départs
les plus propres possibles et ensuite
sur les efforts c'est effectivement
exactement le type d'effort qu'ils
auront à réaliser le week-end prochain
donc sur les championnats de France
handisport
le décompte est lancé
les amateurs de grand braquet sont prêts
à avaler les kilomètres sur la piste
berrichonne
on est chez nous on maîtrise tous les
paramètres
cette piste ils y roulent dessus depuis
plus de 3 ans
effectivement on a toujours un avantage
quand on joue à domicile
autre rendez-vous les championnats du
monde du sport adapté qui se dérouleront
à Vichy et bujoint 2023 ou les épreuves
surpiste seront elles aussi organisées à
Bourges